welcome back to on sensor Donald Trump
last night became the first Republican
presidential candidate to win open races
in both Iowa and New Hampshire a feat
only accomplished before by setting
president you got 55% of the vote in New
Hampshire making a presidential rematch
between Trump and Biden looking now all
but certain Nikki Haley Trump's only
remaining rival for the GOP nomination
pledged to fight on though telling her
supporters there are dozens of States
left to go and there are but there will
be increasing pressure Trump keeps
winning for her to pull out too
President Biden meanwhile on the New
Hampshire Democrat primary as a writing
candidate little known Challenger Dean
Phillips managed very creditable 20% a
measure perhaps of the president deep
unpopularity approval ratings are
currently at 33% and no incumbent
president has ever been reelected with
approval numbers that low well I'm
joined Now by Lara Trump sen advisor of
Donald Trump's presidential campaign and
his daughter-in-law it must be said and
by the political commentator Benny
Johnson well welcome to both of you um
Lara great to have you on uncensored
thank you you you're a great singer I
happen to know this from my oh my
knowledge of your family um and you once
recorded a cover of Tom Petty's song I
Won't Back Down and I can't think of a
more appropriate song to describe your
father-in-law who looked dead and bury
politically 18 months ago and is now
right back where he wants to be uh in
fact winning in a way he didn't do when
he first got elected president in 2016
with Iowa and New Hampshire how has he
done this
he's amazing I mean Piers you know he
this is this is a guy who really won't
back down and I think any other human
being on this planet quite frankly with
all that he has had against him would
have said enough I mean I think we we
can all pretty clearly see the goal of
so much of what they've done to Donald
Trump and whether they being the
Department of Justice obviously that has
been weaponized against him in so many
respects the mainstream media here in
this country his opponents in the swamp
in Washington DC man they've leveled
everything at him and he's not backing
down he's not giving up any normal
person would but I really do believe he
understands what's at stake right now in
this country and really for the rest of
the world um it is our job to be the
leader of the Free World I think in in
the United States and we've always taken
that very seriously right now we are in
a weaken State we have a weak President
we have an economy that's not doing well
people across this country are suffering
they want Donald Trump back I think he
knows he's the only shot and you know
what he's in to win it and and yeah
we've had a couple of great primaries
and caucuses 2 and0 now we're going to
go on and uh head to November 5th you
know my phone went on Monday night I was
just about to come in to do the show and
it was Donald and we hadn't spoken since
our rather contentious interview we did
actually launching this show a while ago
but a very nice chat and I got to say he
was exuding chilling confidence about
what is happening he really just
believes he's going to
win yeah I and I think he believes
because the American people believe I
mean you look at the way he's made
history and the first two tests really
of him as a candidate for president
again and it's it's not even fair to
call him that I mean so many people kind
of consider him an incumbent in so many
ways but he proved himself here in 2016
when the people of this country said we
want to give an outsider a businessman a
shot how will he do it was amazing he
did things in four years in this country
that most presidents wouldn't dream of
doing in two full terms in office um and
so I think he is feeling confident you
saw he had a blowout win in Iowa and
then to go to New Hampshire a state that
if Nikki Haley had any shot at winning
any state across this country in a
primary race against Donald Trump she
would want to be in New Hampshire
because that's where they have of course
an Open Primary people who are not
affiliated with the Republican Party
didn't come vote and you look at the win
he had last night it was really amazing
L I remember him saying to me once I
remember him saying to me once that he
said you got to you got to win he say
Muhammad Ali said you know if you're
going to uh talk the talk you got to
walk the walk or the ACT doesn't play uh
Benny let me bring you in you've be
waiting patiently here um one of the
great advantages that Donald Trump has
is that in 20120 Joe Biden was able to
run as the anti-trump after a very
difficult year for the country with the
pandemic which wrecked all Trump's
economic plans as it did everywhere
around the world um this time Biden has
to run on his own record and his
approval rating says it all on almost
every key policy initiative from
immigration to the economy to Crime you
name it he's in the tank with the
American people um that has got to help
Donald Trump hasn't it in a general
election yeah like not good not a great
strategy actually what Democrats have
done first off could you imagine being a
Joe Biden voter right now like C can you
name a single accomplishment that you'd
be particularly proud of there's nothing
less cool than being a Joe Biden voter
especially as a young person and that is
why you're seeing young people abandoned
Joe Biden I'm looking at NBC News
polling right now in front of me the
number one problem with Joe Biden's
Coalition young people are abandoning
Joe Biden Donald Trump is winning with
voters ages 18 to 34 46% to 42% when was
the last time you saw that for a
Democrat but it gets even worse Donald
Trump is leading with Hispanics and Joe
Biden has collapsed
in his support with black Americans down
to 63% a collapse of 25 points since
taking office also they have turned
Donald Trump into a gangster that also a
big mistake you've made an icon out of
your political rival you've given him a
mug shot as you can see here behind me
in the studio this is totally hardcore
ratchet stuff that kids actually love
that's become a meme online and you've
turned the man who was already an
American icon into a bigger icon
everybody likes voting for the political
prisoner and you uh done effed up demat
and you know what Donald Trump is the
only person I know where if he was
actually convicted of any one of the
things he's been charged with and
actually put into a prison cell he's the
only person I know that could probably
still win the presidential election
because the more they try and throw the
stuff at him the more popular he gets
Piers Chris Rock uh had a comedy set
that he did in Washington DC with Nancy
py in the audience and Chris Rock said
you're gonna turn Donald Trump into Tac
he's gonna sell more records yeah you're
stupid and well Nancy p got Smith and
slapped him in the face it's actually
very interesting you mention uh Chris
Rob because I was at the New York Knicks
in Manhattan the day after the 2016
election and I found myself at a table
sitting next to Chris Rock and we got
talking and I said to him why do you
think Hillary Clinton lost you went let
me tell you why I said because if
someone's murdered eight people don't go
around telling everyone he's murdered
nine and the point he was making was if
you wildly exaggerate everything with
Trump and let's be honest I mean even
Lara would admit he's probably not the
most Angelic human being ever put on to
God's Earth I would never admit such a
thing here please but I don't think you
and he would admit that you see that as
a Badge Of Dishonor but the you know the
reality is that this constant
attempt to take him down uh culminating
in the hypocrisy in my view of the
liberal side led by senior Democrats up
and down the country saying we've got to
get rid of trump and stoping running
again to save democracy and then they
try and remove him from presidential
State ballots which of course is the
most blatant example of trying to thwart
democracy and allowing Americans to have
a free vote imaginable so there's a kind
of nonsensical hypocrisy but also as you
mentioned a stupidity which is him
hardcore if you try and K kill him off
this way and all it does is make him
more popular stop doing it you know the
definition of insanity is doing the same
thing over again and expecting a
different result people identify with
him Pierce people who feel like the
system here has screwed them for their
entire life they look at that mug shot
of Donald Trump by the way the Democrats
thought that was it that was going to be
the nail in the coffin for him that mug
shot that mug shot represents to so many
people all across this country hey the
same system that hasn't been working for
me is working against him and I
understand it and I see myself in that
they done messed up with that one how
much has he made from that mug shot I
heard he was merchandising it and making
an absolute Fortune it's all for the
campaign we should actually keep a tab I
had Christmas wrapping paper with the
mug shot on it you've turned him into a
rebel right you've made him the Sex
Pistols you've turned him into the
Ramones he's now a rebel and kids like
voting for The Rebel again again Benny I
would I would again bring this back to
to Joe Biden the great Advantage Trump
has is the condition of the the sitting
president this is a clip of Biden
yesterday trying to pronounce the name
of the country he
represents we'll teach Donald Trump an
valuable lesson don't mess with the wom
America unless you want to get the
benefit I think he was trying to say
United States of America but he just he
couldn't get it out and we see endless
clips of him falling over on stage
falling off bicycles tripping down the
steps of Air Force One and so on he's up
against Trump a a a very old 81 year old
not because he's 81 because Mick
Jagger's a few months younger and is as
fit as a fiddle it's just he looks like
he's 181 and if you're Trump you must be
licking your lips that this guy's going
to be your
opponent it would be bad enough he if it
was if it was just that by the way but
it's also that coupled with the fact
that everything's a disaster around Joe
Biden right I'm sorry to cut you off
Benny but that's the truth is you can
lie to people and you can try and do the
jazz hands that the Democrats do with
the media all the time only so long but
whenever it hits people's bottom line
when they know that their life is harder
right now in addition to seeing stuff
like that I mean you're exactly right
Joe Biden is basically serving up the
entire thing to us right now I hope that
uh that there's no uh funny business
with 3:00 am dumps this time around
that's all Benny I mean in the end Trump
he's got some stage got to choose a vice
president pick who if you were him who's
the smart play for
Trump the smart play is absolutely
somebody who's young enough and
energetic enough to carry forward the
Maga movement Donald Trump will get
constitutionally one term in office so
you have to pick someone who's not going
to backstab you like a Mike Pence and
somebody who's not going to betray you
like a Nikki Haley and so you should
choose somebody like either Tucker
Carlson or V Ron Swami who are True
Believers but are younger and who have
this long stretch of a political career
ahead of them so that you have a torch
to pass when you are done with term two
okay Lara what your thoughts on VP pick
you probably know well I I well I
wouldn't and I would never break any
news here tonight of course that's not I
want you to break news if I did know uh
I listen I agree with with Benny I think
that you've seen a lot of of the youth
coming into this party in a way that
really I think was very unexpected for
people look at V and I mean the energy
this guy brings I was on stage with him
last night with my father-in-law he's
incredible but whoever it is I can
guarantee you this they will be an
America First Patriot they will be
somebody who as Benny said will carry
the mantle of this movement because he
changed my father-in-law changed the
entire face of politics in this country
he changed the Republican party it will
have to be someone who is in line with
him on that front um and it's it's
exciting stuff we're breaking history
history over here you mentioned change
there so I want to just ask you maybe a
more difficult question I've seen
glimpses of your father-in-law when he
made his victory speech in Iowa not so
much after New Hampshire but in Iowa of
the kind of
charm um civility decency uh that I saw
a lot of when I did the Celebrity
Apprentice over the boardroom table for
week in week out um which he's been
reluctant to show actually when he's
been a politician is he a is HE capable
at his age now of actually pivoting to a
slightly more dare I say if he was to be
reelected a less bombastic suddenly more
inclusive
president well it is Donald Trump uh so
to make a prediction like that uh would
be you know he he'll do what he thinks
is best and the interesting thing with
him is yeah you probably saw two very
different Donald Trumps in the Iowa uh
victory speech and in last night's New
Hampshire victory speech but he chooses
his tone based on the moment and I think
his tone was very appropriate in Iowa
and quite frankly last night I feel like
it was very appropriate as well right
now we have an election to win we do not
need to be fighting within the
Republican party for the obvious
Republican nominee to actually take that
title we should Galvanize our support
together we should go forward we should
make sure that we leave nothing to
chance on November 5th because we have
to take back the White House peers we
have no other option in this country and
quite frankly I don't think the rest of
the world has another option but to have
Donald Trump back in the white house I
think the rest of world is in a mixture
of shock and awe and horror and delight
and curiosity at the impending return of
Donald Trump the Teflon Dawn uh we shall
see it's going to be a fascinating year
Lara great to see you thank you so much
send the family Qui Benny final word to
may I ask you a question may I ask you a
question yeah this is a question that
The Internet's been asking for a very
long time and we don't have an answer
and it must come from you
sir were you in a movie with Donald
Trump called home alone too that is were
you the kitchen lady that is not me home
alone to I'm grateful for the chance to
put the record straight help Kevin
that's actually a female actress it's
not me it looks nothing like there's no
shame in it
Pi no sh not the pigeon lady in Home
Alone too although I do go in Central
Park a lot and I can see the resemblance
but it's not me but thank thank you
Benny I appreciate it you got your viral
moment you
bleep good to have you on the program
too